good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world and so to help you on your journey
today's message is break the rules over
to you simon Sinek let me tell you a
story so a friend of mine and I we went
for a run in Central Park the
Roadrunners organization on the weekends
they host races and it's very common at
the end of the race I'll have a sponsor
who will give away something apples or
bagels or something and on this
particular day when we got to the end of
the run there were some free bagels and
they had picnic tables set up and on one
side was a group of volunteers on the
table were boxes of bagels and on the
other side was a long line of runners
waiting to get their free bagel so I
said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel and he looked at me and said that
lines too long and I said free bagel and
he said I don't want to wait in line and
I was like free bagel and he says not
that's it's too long and that's when I
realized that there's two ways to see
the world some people see the thing that
they want and some people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want I could only see
the bagels he could only see the line
and so I walked up to the line I leaned
in between two people put my hand in the
box and pulled out two bagels and no one
get mad at me
because the rule is you can go after
whatever you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it
you can do it your way you can break the
rules you just can't get in the way of
somebody else getting what they want
that's rule number one
so I'm not necessarily a huge advocate
of cutting in line to get what you want
and I think it's mostly because it's
getting what you want at the expense of
somebody else right like you're cutting
in line and that means somebody else is
losing out it's the same thing for me
when I'm driving and this is really long
left turn lane I hate when people
suggest that cages drive up on the right
side and the last second kind of cut in
because to my own benefit I'm screwing
over the people behind me I don't think
the world has to be that way like you
can go and see the world as I'm going to
make things better for myself and in the
process help everybody else instead of
hurt everybody else I think that's what
entrepreneurs do and I think in terms of
breaking the rules anytime there's a
rule that I feel is really holding me
back I'm frustrated understand that most
rules were created by people who who
were just like you were no smarter than
you and they're created for the average
person right it's like how average
people should live their life and should
operate and that can be very frustrating
for somebody who doesn't want to be
average at something and so it's
understanding what are the rules that
you can break and then add from an
entrepreneurial perspective how do we do
that in a way that can serve other
people I think that's one of the key
differences between entrepreneurs and
the rest of the world is that when we
see something that we don't like when we
see a rule that is really frustrating
most people will just complain they'll
complain the wine to tell their friends
they'll post on social media they'll
just get really upset we're
entrepreneurs we will still get upset
but we'll use that anger and frustration
and turn it into something positive out
of every crisis out of every negativity
out of every
frustration there's a positive there's
something that can be created on the
other side that can solve that
frustration not just for us but for
other people as well
and the bigger that frustration is the
more people are complaining about it the
greater the opportunity there is to
create something really really
meaningful and special for the planet so
I think the key understanding is to
figure out which rules you can break and
which ones you shouldn't
if you just follow life around and you
follow every single rule
you're never gonna create anything
amazing extraordinary insanely special
because you have to be a bit of a rule
breaker to create something new
otherwise you're just living an average
life but if you're breaking every single
rule that ever exists you're probably
going to end up dead or in jail
really really really quickly and so it's
understanding what are the rules you can
break and again having that perspective
of I'm gonna break this rule not just to
help myself but I'm gonna help the
people around me as well so the question
today today is I'm curious what is a
rule that you have broken recently that
has helped you and help the people
around you really curious to find out
leave it down in the comments below I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Tom Bennett Tom thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I really appreciate the support and
I hope you enjoy the week so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
the people who became the most
successful in our society are people who
broke the rules you know there was no
presidents for 24-hour news cycles until
Ted Turner did it there's so many people
who got out of the box look at Apple and
the birth of the whole notion of Apple
or Nike I talk about in the book of the
birthing of that corporation how they
did something with the tennis shoe that
had never been done before if you only
base your decisions on empirical data
you can only repeat what somebody else
already did if you follow your instincts
in your own god-given creativity you we
can go where we have not been before and
our nation used to do that we have so
many doors in life about everything I
said break the rules not the law but
break the rules my wife has a t-shirt my
wife has a t-shirt that says
well-behaved women really and make
history well you know I don't want to
burst her bubble but the same is true
with man it is impossible to be a
maverick or true original if you're too
well behaved and don't want to break the
rules you have to think outside the box
that's what I believe after all what is
the point of being on this earth if all
you want to do is be like to everyone in
avoid trouble the only way that ever got
any place was the breaking some of the
rules after all I remember that after
was finished with my bodybuilding career
I wanted to get into acting and I want
to be a star in films you can imagine
what the agent said when I went to meet
all those agents everyone has the same
line that it can't be done the rules are
different here just look at your body
here if this huge monster his body and
overly developed that doesn't fit into
the movies you don't understand
this was 20 years ago the Hercules
movies now there's the little guys that
ain't Dustin Hoffman Woody Allen Chuck
Nicholson before he gained weight of
course that is but anyway those are the
guys that win and the agent also
complained about Max and he says no one
ever became a star with an accent like
that especially not with the German
accent in yes I can imagine with your
name Arnold Schwarzenegger or whatever
the name is on a billboard yeah that's
gonna draw a lot of tickets and sell a
lot of tickets you're right so this is
the kind of negative attitude there
but I didn't listen and listen to those
rules even though they were very nice
and they said look we can get you some
big parts be kingmaker get you to be a
you know playing a wrestler or a bouncer
or maybe be the German accent we can get
it to be a Nazi officer in Hogan's
Heroes or something like that but you
know I didn't listen to all this this
was their rules not my rules
I was convinced that could do it that if
I worked as hard as I didn't
bodybuilding five hours a day and I
started getting to work I started taking
acting classes took English classes took
speech classes dialogue classes accent
removal classes I even took I remember
running around a fine wine grows on a
vine is it because Germans had
difficulties with the F and the W and
the V it's a fine wine grows and the
vine I know what some of you now say is
I hope that Arnold got his money back
but the middle is something I had a good
time doing those things and it really
helped me finally I throat through I
broke through and I started getting the
first parts in TB streets of San
Francisco Lucille Ball hired me and made
pumping iron stay hungry and then I got
the big break in Conan the Barbarian and
there the director said if we wouldn't
have Schwarzenegger we would have to
build one now think about that and then
when I did Terminator I'll be back
became most of one of the most famous
lines in a movie history
all because of my crazy accent now think
about it the things that the agent said
will be totally a detriment and will be
impossible for me to get a job all of a
sudden became an asset for me all of the
things my accent my body and everything
so it just shows you never listen that
you can't do something and you have to
work your way up of course run for
something else first I mean it was the
same when I ran for governor the same
lines that if the rug you wrap it can't
be done and then of course I ran for
governor and the rest of course is
history they said you have to start with
a small job as mayor and then there's a
simply man and then he was lieutenant
governor and then as governor and he
said that's the way it works in a
political career I said I'm not
interested
the political Korea I want to be a
public servant I want to fix
California's problems and bring people
together and bring the parties together
so like I said I decided to run I didn't
pay attention to the rules and I made it
and the rest is history